الى روسيا تشير اصابع الاتهام بشان عمليه
التسريب الاخيره للوثائق العسكريه وثائق
ممهوره بعباره سري للغايه تتعلق بالامن
القومي الامريكي والشرق الاوسط ومنطقه
اسيا وفي موسكو استخفاف بالاتهام وتقليل
منه اذ ان هناك اتجاه عاما لتحميل روسيا
مسؤوليه كل شيء
لكن خطوره عمليه التسريب تتخطى السجال
السياسي فالتسريب هذا يعد الخرق الامني
الاخطر منذ ما كشفه المتعقد السابق مع
وكاله الامن القومي الامريكي
لعشره الاف الوثائق ومقاطع الفيديو
والبرقيات الدبلوماسيه عام 2013
وفي الحالتين تحضر روسيا متهما او مساندا
في افضل الاحوال من وجهه النظر الامريكيه
في يونيو حزيران عام 2013 سرب ادوارد
سنودن مليونا و700,000 وثيقه كشفت عن
فضائح تجسس على مواطنين امريكيين ومسؤولين
اجانب بما في ذلك قاده دول حليفه للولايات
المتحده تورطت بها وكاله الامن القومي
والاستخبارات الامريكيه
الوثائق اثناء وجوده في هونج كونج التي
غادرها متوجها الى روسيا على ان ينتقل
بعدها الى امريكا الجنوبيه
وخلال وجوده في موسكو الغت حكومه الولايات
المتحده جواز سفره فبقي في روسيا وطلب
اللجوء السياسي ليمنحه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في ايلول سبتمبر الماضي
الجنسيه الروسيه مع زوجته فيما اعتبر
اصرار الروسيا على ضمان امن الرجل
لماذا وفرت روسيا الحمايه لسنودن سؤال
يضعها في خانه المشتبه فيه والى ان تتكشف
ادله تثبت الاتهام او تنفيه فان وزاره
العدل الامريكيه بدات تحقيقا جديدا في
التسريبات الاخيره
العلاقه بين واشنطن وعمليات التسريب مزمنه
فقبل سنودن كان موقع ويكيليكس ومؤسسه
جوليا السونش في عام 2009 2010 نشر الموقع
مئات الاف الوثائق ومقاطع الفيديو المسربه
من العراق وافغانستان بما فجر فضيحه عن
اخلاقيات الجيش الامريكي وجنوده في مناطق
القتال ومنذ ذلك الحين بدا السونش رحله
الفرار واللجوء الى ان اخرجته الاكوادور
من سفارتها في لندن وسلمته للسلطات
البريطانيه